wir sprechen über Politiker die uns
Energiespartipps geben wir dachten damit
ist es ehrlich gesagt endlich mal vorbei
aber falsch ja baden-Württembergs
Ministerpräsident Winfried Kretschmann
der mit dem Waschlappen Tipp sie
erinnern sich der legt jetzt nach
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger auch
heute geht es mir um sparen genauer
gesagt ums Energie sparen ja
Energiesparen mit baden-Württembergs
Ministerpräsident Winfried Kretschmann
also der hat jetzt bezahlt von
Steuergeld diese neue große eigene
Energie spar-kampagne gestartet und zwar
unter dem Namen cleverland
diese Kampagne die startet kretscht man
mit diesem Video erkennen sie ihn ja da
sagt er nämlich das erst im Grunde schon
immer gewusst hat die Energiesparen das
geht schon als junger Mann ja mit dem
Wasser
zum Beispiel mit zwei stufenregelung
macht viele haben damals gelacht aber
dies schwarze Prinzip hilft uns heute
allen so sieht's aus Winfried
Kretschmann also baden-Württembergs
Ministerpräsident cleverland seine neue
Kampagne und wir schauen mal rein um was
es dort für Energiespartipps geht
was früher die zwei stufenregelung bei
der Klospülung war ist heute die
Nachtabsenkung bei der Heizung tagsüber
wenn sie sich in der Wohnung aufhalten
wird geheizt und nachts wenn alle
schlafen wird die Heizung runtergefahren
das kann jede und jeder an seine Heizung
selbst einstellen und wem das zu
kompliziert ist einfach Form ins Bett
gehen den Thermostaten runterdrehen
toll jetzt wissen Sie Bescheid und er
sagt nämlich auch selbst wenn muss kein
clevere sein um diese Tipps zu verstehen
auch das schickt er noch einmal
hinterher jetzt begrüßen wir Ralf
schuller-chef unseres parlamentsbüros
hier bei uns im Studio und du bist auch
ein clever wenn es um Thema
Energiesparen geht aber jetzt mal
ehrlich wie findest du diese Tipps wie
habt ihr gerade die Temperatur
eingestellt ist muss ich noch etwas
runterdrücken über Nacht war es kalt
haben wir uns natürlich daran gehalten
findest du das ist ein Zumutung also
muss man mal ehrlich sagen man kann es
ja auch man kann es ja locker nehmen
aber die Politik hat einfach einen
gewissen
Privatsektor des Menschen zu achten in
der freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
zumindest früher haben wir das auch
gemacht da haben wir immer alles
gesammelt der Ressourcen von Sozialismus
das DDR kommt alles einfach wieder in
der DDR groß geworden bin da
aufgewachsen wir haben dann Altstoffe
gesammelt und mit jedem Gramm Material
sind wir sehr sorgsam umgegangen weil
der Sozialismus aufgebaut werden musste
solche Tipps hier kann ich nicht mehr
sehen also das hat mit Politikern nichts
zu tun das ist außerdem auch noch so
primitiv jeder einzelne ich weiß das
jeder weiß dass er vorm Schlafen die
Temperatur so einstellt dass er schlafen
kann die meisten Heizungen haben ohnehin
Tag und nachtprogramme es ist völliger
Blödsinn was er da erzählt und es ist
einfach zu dringlich es ist einfach
aufdringlich in meine Privatsphäre rein
es hat sich bei Corona eingebürgert dass
man irgendwie in den Privatbereich der
Menschen reinregiert hat ihnen
vorgeschrieben hat wie viel Familien
sich mit wie vielen Leuten in im
Wohnzimmer zu treffen haben und das geht
jetzt mit der Energie weiter es ist
übergriffig die Politik muss einfach
lernen dass es einen Bereich gibt der
sie nichts angeht da kann man
appellieren wir sollen alle
Energiesparen den Rest machen wir dann
schon selber vielen Dank herr
Kretschmann clever lernt diese Kampagne
hätte er sich also sparen sollen auf
jeden Fall ich meine man kann immer ganz
gerne mit dem Slang in Baden-Württemberg
ein bisschen spielen wir können alles
außer Hochdeutsch aber nicht so ein
Unsinn und nicht als Ministerpräsident
wenn man da ein Merkblatt rausgibt
reicht das völlig wenn man meint dass
die Menschen danach wohlbedarf haben er
hält uns offenbar für blöd
da habe ich überhaupt kein Verständnis
für merkt Tipps geben hätte gereicht das
sagt Ralf Schuler Chef unseres
parlamentsbüros der kein Verständnis für
cleverland
[Musik]